hi I'm Gary gem from harvest Farm in
Whateley Massachusetts I've got a
wholesale vegetable farm with my partner
Dave and we specialize in certain
brassicas primarily collard greens and
kale we grow tomatoes peppers eggplant
some herbs and greenhouse crops we grow
about a hundred acres of crops most of
it as brassicas cultivation is a big
part of our weed control program
herbicides are used as well as hand
hoeing and cultivation using various
different techniques and tools we find
that we can grow some of our crops with
no herbicides and only cultivation and
other growing techniques with the
brassicas we find that we need to use a
combination of herbicides and
cultivation in particularly weedy fields
we may have to get out and hand hoe but
what we're looking for in the long term
is to clean up our fields and get them
to a point where we reduce hand hoeing
to a minimum but when we have to seed
crops directly into the field we find
that we need to use a pre-emergent
herbicide usually just to get a jump on
the seeds coming out of the ground
before we get to to whether we use
cultivation or herbicides or both really
starts with the crop rotation we have a
three year rotation program here on the
farm
to try and keep diseases and weeds at
bay we find that it works quite well for
diseases but the weed pressure is always
there we're trying to do better and
better all the time but it seems like
the weeds are getting tougher and
tougher to deal with - so we start with
the rotation that tells us where we can
plant
certain crops certain families of crops
and we look then at the conditions weed
pressures in the different fields and
decide where to try to farm with no
herbicides where to farm with them and
what herbicides we may have to use and
basically our whole approach to farming
those fields so this tool here is the
basis of our establishing a clean field
from very early on and this combined
with making a bed to get a smooth
surface gives us the capability of doing
a good job to start with once we get a
little bit of weed pressure and our
transplants are still small enough we
run through with this Cub tractor and
the budding cages we slide right in
between the plants and do a nice job of
cleaning everything up except what's in
between the rows are in the rows and
that serves us as our first cultivation
and after that we go in with a different
tractor we can do an acre in about a
half an hour with this and my goal is to
always go as fast as I can speed seems
to to really make a big difference with
this thing if the plants are tall enough
and the ground is firm enough I've gone
in Rhode gear with it and really been
pleased with the results you also like
to get your work done quickly but you
want to do a good job and that's the
primary goal when we find conditions are
particularly clumpy such as after heavy
rains before we go in for the hilling we
will frequently go in with these small
teeth with these little wires attached
to them to break up the clods so that
when we Hill we don't throw the clods
all over the plants and do more damage
than good these we found hanging around
in an old barn and put them to use they
work quite well for for fracturing the
soil
the key to doing a good job is to have a
nice straight flatbed that the
cultivators can follow to a tee this
system works well enough that the
tractor virtually does it itself as a
matter of fact one time I was chased by
some mean bees and I jumped off the
tractor and it caught up to me at the
end of the row and it had cultivated
perfectly all the way along without me
on it after we go through with the
budding cultivators we then leave the
crop alone pretty much until it gets to
a stage of growth where we can just
sneak in one last time and that's when
we come in with this tractor with the
big sweeps on it and we adjust them the
cultivating shanks are adjustable so
that the teeth are tipped down not as
they are now but they're pointed more
towards the ground and we go through and
Hill them up and top dress them at the
same time now so far with the use of the
buttons we've achieved weed control in
between the rows once we come in with
these particular cultivators we achieve
weed control within the row because we
Hill up the dirt around the plants and
we can vary weeds up to about two inches
in height we do that just prior to the
canopy filling in and usually when we go
in we also add fertilizer to give the
crop enough food to carry it to maturity